oh yeah what is going on I am Justin
from learn English with TV series and
real-life English we help you not just
learn English but to live it and today
we're gonna help you live your English
with super hilarious TV series seen from
friends in which Joey confuses the word
omnipotent for I'm impotent first I want
to invite you to download this free PDF
power lesson which covers the entire
scene explains everything you need to
know about vocabulary pronunciation
grammar culture notes and it has a
transcription download it by pressing
the button above or clicking on the link
in the information box our method is
simple you watch the scene with
subtitles you study it you learn it
we're gonna teach you everything in this
lesson today and then you watch it
without subtitles and that's what we
mean by not just learning it living it I
would want world peace no more hunger
good things for the rainforest and
bigger boobs No
so you took mine Chen Li what about you
if I were omnipotent for a day I'd make
myself out nipping it forever say
there's always one guy Vitae wish I'd
wish for three more wishes
jillee everybody hey Joey what would you
do if you were omnipotent let me kill
myself
excuse me hey if little Joey's dead then
I got no reason
Joey I'm nificant you are
if I run diffident for a day I would
want omnipotent the quality of having
unlimited power
for example stories of omnipotent Greek
gods I would want world peace no more
hunger good thanks for the rain forest
hunger hungry hunger is the feeling you
have when you need to eat for example he
ate a whole pizza and even that didn't
satisfy his hunger rain forest a forest
that receives a lot of rain and his
dense and vegetation for example the
Amazon is the world's largest rain
forest in bigger boobs boobs cloak word
for woman's breasts China what about you
what about you used to ask somebody's
opinion or choice or information in
response to information already
presented for example I'm from the USA
what about you or I'm gonna have another
beer what about you another phrase used
in a very similar way is how about you
for example they're coming home tonight
to watch the game how about you buddy by
the way I'd wish for three more wishes a
wish something you have a strong desire
or want for their wish is to help people
from the poor areas of the city or it
uses a verb one day I wish to speak
Mandarin what would you do if you're
omnipotent what would you do what would
you do if you were omnipotent let me
kill myself
kill myself let me kill myself the
second conditional a Myra I'm nipping it
for day I would want world peace if I
were omnipotent for a day I would want
world peace the second conditional in
this case is used to express imaginary
situation and its result in this
structure in the if part of the sentence
the verb is conjugated as past and we
put would before the verb in the result
part for example if I lived near the
beach I would be a surfer if I had more
money I would travel more if little
Joey's dead then I got no reason little
Joey Joey here refers to his private
part but putting little in front of a
name can also be used to describe a
child if I too wish I'd wish for three
more wishes if I had a wish I'd wish for
three more wishes
Rachel's comment here is in reference to
the tendency of trying to be smart in
the three wish game by wishing for more
wishes
Joey omnipotent omnipotent versus I am
impotent
Joey's apparently confusing omnipotent
for I'm impotent or said faster I'm
impotent okay if I rounded it for a day
I would want world peace no more hunger
good thanks for the rainforests and
bigger boobs
so you took mine Chandler what about you
if I were omnipotent for a day I'd make
myself up nipping it forever say there's
always one guy Vitae wish I'd wish for
three more wishes hey buddy
hey Joey what would you do if you were
omnipotent let me kill myself
excuse me hey if little Joey's dead then
I got no reason Joey omnipotent you are
did you love this lesson then remember
to click here to join our free
three-part mini course
teaching you English with your favorite
TV series